TV William C Davis is the author of look
away it examines the social economic and
political background of the South during
a civil war and offers an alternative
reading of the Confederates as
revolutionaries it's 45 minutes thank
you very much it's a pleasure to be here
and especially to introduce Jack Davis a
native of Independence Missouri
Jack earned his bachelor's and master's
degree at Sonoma State University in
California he has had a wide range of
experiences and magazine editing book
publishing but for our purposes tonight
he's best known as the author or editor
of more than 40 books and for his
frequent appearances on television
documentaries such as Civil War journal
a jack is one the Jefferson Davis award
three times an award given for book
length works in Confederate history and
he's been twice nominated for the
Pulitzer Prize
he has written a series of deeply
researched in beautifully written books
that have had great appeal for general
readers as well as for historians of the
Civil War II er the range of topics Jack
has covered is impressive ranging from
biographies of leading Confederate
figures such as Jefferson Davis and John
C Breckinridge to military studies that
battles a full run a new market to a
wonderful book in the relationship
between Abraham Lincoln and northern
soldiers during the past decade jack has
published a series of books related to
the political history of the Confederate
States of America including his
masterful work a government of our own
the making of the Confederate
in a time when political history no
longer attracts either the general or
academic interest that it once commanded
Jack Davis has literally breathed life
back into this important field of study
and now and for our purposes tonight he
has just published a general history of
the Confederate States of America that
is sure to become a landmark work in
civil war history in his writing as you
will soon hear and is speaking Jack
brings a breadth of knowledge infectious
enthusiasm and emphysema
to a wide range of topics it's my
pleasure to welcome William C Jack Davis
really tickle to get see my old friend
George Ribble and others here and thank
you all for for coming out maybe I ought
to dispel some confusion first of all
can you hear me at all
okay George referred to me as Jack my
name is William C Davis how do you get
Jack out of William you take some doing
it chiefly comes from the fact that even
as a child I hated the name Bill if any
of you have the name Bill I am happy
that you have it but I just didn't like
being a bill and somehow Jack got
applied to me and I am comfortable with
it
so people are often confused who's this
William Davis and who's this Jack Davis
I thought I'd just chat with you for a
while and then maybe take some questions
afterward on what the books about and
what I was setting out to do on the
right over here with my delightful
escort we were discussing Shakespeare
and I could almost open up with Marc
Anthony's oration over Caesar you know I
I come not to praise the Confederacy but
to bury it but I'm not I'm not here to
bury the Confederacy I'm not here to
criticize it I'm not here to praise it
either one nor to apologize for it my
goal is simply to understand it as a
dramatic human event in our American
past and is a far more complex
experiment in democracy than most people
realize today unfortunately we tend to
view the we don't get much Confederate
history in in our schooling and never
have but we're usually you only get
about two weeks for the whole Civil War
era in high school anymore that's not
much time to cram an awful big subject
into the result being that most
Americans if they know anything about
the Confederacy are operating from one
of two one-dimensional stereotypes
either
that it was a monument to constitutional
Liberty into constitutional government
and to strict construction of the
Constitution or if the other extreme
that it was a monument to ancient
right-wing reactionary efforts to
entrench slavery in American society
both are wrong but both are also right
in a way but it's far more complex than
that
yes the Confederate founding fathers
were in some degree reactionary but they
were also reformers believe it or not
and I'll talk about that a little bit
later certainly some of them were
ideologue but they were also idealists
I mean who conceives of the Confederates
as being idealistic if they were on the
one hand they appear to be standing up
for state rights and localism while on
the other the Confederacy will become by
1865 the most socialized state in
American history until the New Deal
they're very very complex they can't
just be dismissed with simple one or two
dimensional explanations and that's what
I wanted to get into in writing this
book I stayed off of the battlefield not
because military history is unimportant
to paraphrase Bill Clinton it was a war
stupid and indeed contrary to what a
number of historians are saying recently
maintaining that the Confederacy lost
was defeated because of poor morale at
home because the women lost heart in the
war because Confederates lost their
faith in God there all these
explanations my favorite is that the
South lost because he didn't have the
atomic bomb well they didn't but they'd
have lost even if they have it because
they didn't have a b-29 to deliver it
they're all wrong the Confederacy was
beaten on the battlefield the
Confederacy's beaten not by its own
internal weaknesses of which there are
many it's beaten by Abraham Lincoln and
u.s. grant overwhelming Union might and
the willingness of the people of the
north to stay with that war as long as
it took by 1865 the Confederates have
achieved essentially full mobilization
meaning that every man between the
military ages of 16 and 50 who was
willing to be sent into the armies had
gone the only men who aren't there are
those who are physically unable
or those who were deserters or those who
are simply hiding in the hills because
they aren't willing to go even if morale
was 100 percent wonderful it can't
create more people and they simply never
had enough men but that doesn't mean
that what's happening behind the lines
isn't not only interesting but very
important everything that takes place on
the battlefield is mirrored in what's
happening on the homefront everything
that's happening on the homefront is
mirrored in the Army's you can't
separate the two and so what I wanted to
look at was the political story of the
Confederacy the social story of the
Confederacy and most of all most
interest to me the evolution of what I
call Confederate democracy because the
Confederacy is an experiment in
democracy in a democracy didn't just
spring up full-grown in 1776 or 1787
or even today democracy is a work in
progress and it's changing constantly it
evolves in reaction to crises and
reaction to various stimuli and
Confederate democracy about which I'll
say a little bit in a minute I think was
a natural branch in the evolution of
democracy just as Neanderthal man was a
natural branch of evolution he didn't
work out he couldn't compete the
Confederacy couldn't compete that
doesn't mean it was wrong it just means
evolution you know evolution doesn't
mean improvement it just means things
are tried those that succeed last those
that don't disappear the Confederacy's
one that didn't succeed though for dead
branch of evolution it's taken a long
time to die and that finally I think is
is the the other reason I wanted to get
into this subject because more than any
other aspect of our American past the
Confederacy is still alive today it's in
the newspapers almost daily it's
reflected in our current political
social and cultural values it's still
one of the dominant forces
in our literature and arts and our media
we haven't turned loose of it just as we
haven't turned loose of the Civil War as
a whole and so it deserves I think to be
understood far more than just these
simple cut out stereotypes that we like
to throw at it so a few words about a
few words about what it was or what I
think it was it's still controversial
but if anyone wants to know why
secession came about
don't listen to a historian listen to
the men who made secession happen and
they're unanimous in 1860 and 61 that it
was political issues surrounding slavery
more particularly just the one issue of
the extension of slavery into new
territories and if you can separate
yourselves from the moral and ethical
reverse revulsion we feel today toward
the idea of slavery put yourself in
their shoes in their culture in 1860
slavery is legal it's in the
Constitution from the pulpit from the
press they are told that slavery is an
institution ordained by God that it
represents the natural relation of the
races if they are going to co-exist
together so these men in 1860 are not
apologetic about slavery being the issue
that's driving them and their concern is
there's all this vast new territory to
the west it's been acquired in the
Louisiana Purchase it's been acquired
like parts of Alabama in by session or
treaty from Indian tribes like
California and other areas it's been
taken by conquest from Mexico all of us
north and south contributed our blood in
those wars we contributed our treasure
in those purchases we ought to have an
equal right to enjoy the benefits of
those territories but if Washington
passes laws saying we can't take slaves
into new territories what does that mean
it means none of them are ever going to
have a chance of becoming slave states
and slavery in 1860 is what defines
power in America
up until 1850 there been an equal number
of slave states and free states
I won't lecture you on the Constitution
it will put you to sleep in a nanosecond
but let me remind you of how Congress
works the House of Representatives is
apportioned on the basis of population
but every state gets the same number of
senators in the Senate and legislation
has to pass both houses of Congress so
long as there's an equal number of slave
states to free States that means that
the slave states in the Senate can stop
legislation that might be hostile to the
south or to slavery but if they can't
take slaves into the new territories
there's no chance they'll be able to
make more new slave states which
guarantees eventually the Free State
majority will get bigger and bigger and
the south is doomed to be a perpetual
minority within this democracy and when
that happens it's not hard for them to
fear whether it's a real fear or not
does it matter because people and
nations act on the basis of what we feel
rather than what is we're moved by
emotion and fears and even paranoia
sometimes more than by facts and they
have the fear that one day and
overwhelming Freestate majority can
attack slavery where it exists and if
that happens southern society is sunk
there are millions of people today who
don't honor the bills but when any of
them get away with saying to you that
petroleum is not important in their
lives three quarters of the southern
people don't own slaves but slavery was
still vitally important in their lives
it defined power as I've said already it
powered their economy it defined social
status and a host of other things even
people who didn't own slaves had a stake
in slavery and again if we can separate
ourselves from that the idea of how
awful slavery is to us today from a
purely legalistic standpoint it's hard
not to sympathize with them I think the
southerner slave owner can say look my
neighbor in Illinois can settle the New
Territories with his wagon
that's his property but I can't settle
the new terror
is with what is legally my property
because it's a slave and that is the
issue that's under agitation from 1850
onward and that's the issue that in 1860
finally propels South Carolina to start
secession and I don't ask you to believe
a historian
nobody does as a rule believe the men
who made secession happen robert
Barnwell ret of south carolina the
leading fire-eating secessionist in the
entire nation he'd been preaching
secession for over 35 years in 1860 he
declares publicly slavery is the
occasion that is cause of secession
robert toombs of georgia who was almost
Confederate president and who never
forgave Jefferson Davis for getting the
job he thought he ought to have in 1861
yes slavery is wrong our whole system is
wrong Alexander Stevens of Georgia vice
president of the Confederacy one month
after the Confederacy is formed speaking
in Savannah Georgia the cornerstone of
our movement is the inequality of the
white and black races and Jefferson
Davis Confederate president this is
about slavery this is what they said in
1860 and 61 they all changed their story
in the 1870s and 80s when we have the
beginning of the creation of the Lost
Cause myth this will come as a great
surprise to you I'm sure nobody likes to
lose a war but it's far worse to lose a
war in a cause that the culture of which
you're apart looks on as a bad cause and
by the 1870s Western culture universally
by which I mean not just the Americas
but Europe as well regard slavery as a
bad cause and so the former Confederates
said about the creation of the Lost
Cause myth we've lost the war but maybe
we can win the piece by retro actively
changing why we went to war and that is
the first time that the state rights
argument behind slavery starts to come
out but they as I say they were
unapologetic about slavery being behind
it and we don't need to apologize for
them well that sounds very that sounds
pretty reactionary that sounds pretty
conservative you know trying to preserve
the old landed aristocratic status quo
but then look at what they do when they
come together not far from here in
Montgomery Alabama to frame this new
Confederacy for a start interestingly
enough there was no concerted plan a lot
of people up in Yankee 'dom thought that
there was a conspiracy among these
seceding states to secede and inform a
new nation
nothing's further from the truth they
weren't even talking amongst themselves
South Carolina went off on its own and
hoped other people would follow in fact
in October of 1862 before the election
of 1860 the governor of South Carolina
sent a letter to all the governors of
the other slave states saying if Abraham
Lincoln's elected will you secede and
every other governor wrote back saying
no unless South Carolina does first
there was no coordination at all but
once the session starts they decide they
need to get together and decide what to
do next and so they decide this whole
this convention in Montgomery but only
to talk most of these delegates are sent
there with no power whatever to do
anything they're sent to talk and that's
it but once they get there they realize
that time is running against them
Lincoln's going to take office in March
1861 they can't wait for him to take
control of events they have to do it
first and so these men who have just
finished one revolution start another
revolution against their own states by
taking power they don't have and without
permission without authorization they
create the Confederate States of America
frame a provisional Constitution then
they frame a permanent Constitution they
choose a president who chooses a cabinet
they set up a government they begin an
army and then they go home to their
state saying here it is this is what we
have done take it or leave it
and in some cases they had a hard time
selling this to their home states but at
the same time they're doing this
remember what I said before about them
being idealists and reformers which i OS
the eyebrows go up when I mention this
about the Confederates
for one thing here's an example of
idealism to the point of naivete yet
they thought it would work they believed
they could have a system in which there
would be no political parties and no
partisan politics they'd had two
generations in the old union of seeing
what had happened the crisis of the
Union is deeply tied up in the growth of
political parties and the agitation
between them as one party or another
seeks power I mean this is nothing new
to any of us we see leaders and all of
the major parties using us and using
events to achieve power those who don't
have it wanted those who have it want to
hold on to it and they aren't always
doing the people's business
are they this is nothing new is the same
in the 1830s 40s and 50s but they
thought if we leave the Union will have
left behind all of those sources of
discord and will be one big happy family
we'll all agree with each other this
lasted about 10 seconds because they
were all politicians and they couldn't
gain say their basic nature and in fact
of course the Confederacy will be sort
of a two-party system there's a
wonderful book on it by George Babel the
man who introduced me called the
Confederate Republic that deals with
political parties and politics in the
Confederacy but for an idealistic notion
that we can rise above raw crass
politics and then their reformers when
they frame their constitution they adopt
about 95 percent of the old US
Constitution verbatim but they see
problems in that they hope to redress
they start civil service reform in
America they start term limits in
America by limiting I don't know if you
regard that as a reform or not but it
begins with the Confederates who will
limit their president to one term they
figure if we get a good man we don't
want to lose the last two years of him
while he's wasting time running for
re-election in their constitution they
specifically outlaw pork barrel
legislation they don't want the people's
money being spent by this congressman or
that congressman to build a missile base
in his home district to bolster his
support in his home state the wonderful
irony of course
is that several generations later their
descendants will become the accomplished
masters of pork-barrel legislation they
outlaw Congress appropriating money
Congress cannot initiate appropriations
only the executive can they don't want
congressmen having the power to spend
the people's money perhaps most
interesting of all to me we have this
notion that the Confederates are these
people mired in statute law the
Constitution is something written in
stone this deeply conservative look
backward yet they make it easier to
amend their constitution than it is to
amend the United States Constitution
they wanted a document that was organic
that could respond to challenges into
the exigencies of the present it they
really are reformist and of course by
the way they give their president the
line-item veto Jefferson Davis is the
only one ever to have it until Bill
Clinton had it but I think just what for
two years and then I believe it was
taken away again so these are people who
aren't just looking backward they're
looking forward as well and the way they
administer their government of course
shows almost immediately the
impracticality of what they were hoping
to do in having a nation state that was
decentralized in which power was
diffused to the separate states rather
than concentrated if the war taught
Jefferson Davis above all anything it
was that a weak decentralized nation
cannot survive in a crisis and the story
of the Confederacy from 1861 on is the
story of the steady concentration of
power in Richmond and in the hands of
the President as Davis has to accumulate
more and more authority to meet the
crisis at hand and will hand in hand
with that are increasing challenges to
the individual rights of people who live
in the Confederacy and to the rights of
the states themselves by the end of the
worst the whole idea of state rights has
essentially gone out the window they
have almost all been subsumed to the
National Authority
and as I said earlier on the Confederacy
by 1865 becomes the most socialized
state in our history until the New Deal
and maybe even more in the New Deal by
1865 you have the government controlling
production and distribution of staple
products establishing wage and price
controls for commodities instituting
rationing instituting prohibition
redistributing property wealth in a way
instituting the first draft or
conscription in our history instituting
prog a program of impressment that is
forcible seizure of private property for
the military with compensation at
government rates public welfare mostly
by the states but the federal government
the Confederate government somewhat
involved as well I mean most of this
sounds like what was happening here
during World War two in response to
another crisis yet variations of this
are all taking place in the Confederacy
and by the very end in just after New
Year's in 1865
Jefferson Davis will actually send an
envoy Duncan Kenner from Louisiana
abroad with an offer couched in a hint
to European powers that he would be
willing to use the government to abolish
slavery if European powers would grant
diplomatic recognition to the
Confederacy which they then hoped would
lead to military intervention and he
does this without consulting the
governors of the states slavery which is
always trumped rights at the beginning
of the war at the end of the war is
itself being trumped by the imperative
for survival Davis like so many others
has gone through this incredible
transformation where in 1861 he's
something of a champion of localism by
1865 he's the ultimate nationalist
because he has seen what's necessary to
preserve his nation
and the human story behind this is is I
think the most compelling of all the
most fun in the research for this book
which took a few years was going through
all of the papers of the Confederate
governor's people in America north and
south at that time had this wonderful
feeling of a direct connection between
them and their elected leaders that
we've long since lost because we're too
big now there are innumerable examples
in the Union Army of Union soldiers who
will pass through Washington who will
simply go to the White House to see the
president you get in a line and if the
line moves fast enough they can see the
president usually just to shake hands
say how do you do or say my captain's a
jerk or I'd like a promotion a citizen
had a right to go there but even more
interesting than that are the soldiers
who don't even care about seeing Lincoln
they go to the White House because it's
their house this is the people's house
and you'll find examples of soldiers who
will simply walk into the White House go
to the East Room and sit down and use a
desk for writing their correspondence
they have a right to be there and in the
Confederate States as well you find tens
of thousands of letters written by
average citizens in the Confederacy to
their governors and they expect that
governor to take an interest in their
complaint or their problem or whatever
it is and I went through all of the
letters all of the incoming
correspondence that survives for the
Confederate governors and that's where
you truly I think see the heart and the
soul of the common people of the
Confederacy and where you can engage you
can gauge the experience that they went
through that's where you see the
complaints of the shortage that's where
you see the plaintive cries of the
mothers who have all these children and
the husband's off to war and they can't
get in a crop that's where you see the
people in terror because civil order has
broken down in most of the Confederacy
most of the men are in the war therefore
there are no peacekeepers at home
they're afraid of their slaves they're
afraid of deserters they're afraid of
unionists because the Confederacy is not
a solid South it's rife with unionists
central Alabama had the county of
Winston that's virtually all unionists
Mississippi has the county of Jones it's
virtually all unionist
every Confederate state will send
regiments of white troops into the Union
Army except for South Carolina there is
no solid south and these people are
terrified at home and they're hungry
and they're facing a very uncertain
future and that's all in the papers
written to these governors and what's
also there is the stress and the strain
and the trauma of what happens to them
in four years the common people of the
Confederacy went through about four
generations of democratic evolution
remember just what I said about the
increasing socialization the increasing
assault on personal and property rights
even in peacetime that would be a lot to
absorb but under the strains of war as
well of shortage of hardship of hunger
that was an incredible trauma it's no
wonder that in 1865 when the war ended
the people of the South were just worn
out I think if anything were to come out
of somebody reading this book I'd hope
most of all it would be some
understanding of what these people went
through and some empathy I don't think
the Civil War is something to be
celebrated how do you celebrate the
needless deaths of three-quarters of a
million people and the blighting of a
generation it would be like celebrating
the Holocaust but I think we do need to
know about it we need to understand it
so we can understand its impact on us I
think we ought to approach it with some
reverence but most of all with empathy
for what those people went through and
that's what I have tried to do in the
course of the book I've gone on long
enough if people have questions we've
got some time to have some questions or
discussion if anybody would like to ask
anything yes sir
gnarrk
slaves entering
who the question is wasn't there an
article in the Constitution of the
Confederacy forbidding slaves entering
the Confederate states they did continue
the abolition of the foreign slave trade
which had been enacted in the north and
1807 or 1808 there was a lot of debate
over that people like Rhett and others
one of the slave trade opened up again
because they thought this prohibition
was was a blight was a stain on this
institution that they thought was quite
honorable it's not because they had any
opposition to slavery that they didn't
want the slave trade continued
there are already three and a half
million slaves in the south that's more
than enough they don't need more
furthermore if you import more slaves
you reduce the capital value of the
slaves you have already they had a big
debate all just going on from that for
saying they had a huge debate in the
Constitutional Convention over the issue
of whether or not they should admit free
states remember what I said they're
reformers and idealists they thought
we're going back to the original purity
of the Constitution we're erecting a new
city on a hill here and many Jefferson
Davis thought New Hampshire might secede
and joined the Confederacy that's not a
joke he'd been to New Hampshire one of
their colleges gave him an honorary
degree he figured there are kind of
people but they were good conservative
it was a good conservative Democratic
state at that time many of these men
thought we're not the only ones who are
dissatisfied with what Washington has
been doing to the Union and the
Constitution
some of these free states Illinois
Indiana Ohio they may want to leave the
Union and join us as well
but then they got to thinking what
happens if the whole Union breaks apart
and reconstitutes itself under the
Confederacy it's what happens if we
admit free states due to the Confederacy
will rewrite back where we started there
will be a majority of free states in the
Confederacy and what have we
accomplished so they make it virtually
impossible in their constitution for a
free state to join they also embed in
their constitution the provision that
all Confederate territories will
automatically have slavery it's kind of
pointless because the Confederacy has no
territory
but it's an example of how they hoped to
become a major power and a continental
nation and they hope to acquire
territory probably mostly from Mexico
and Cuba maybe even Central America mega
pardon
well in the New Mexico Territory they
could hope to take it from the Federals
and indeed they do send an expedition
out there in 1861 to try to take it but
further than that they make it all but
impossible for any existing slave state
ever to abolish slavery because if they
start if free states start to appear
among them they can still wind up where
they were before but ask yourselves what
does that say about the doctrine of
state rights a state has the right to
embrace slavery but it doesn't have the
right to reject slavery what it says is
slavery Trump's state rights there was
another hand up here indigo yes
good question did any of the states and
the Confederacy want to secede from the
Confederacy
I think Jefferson Davis wished Georgia
would mainly because of his governor
they the other big debate in the
Confederate constitutional convention is
this very issue of what about secession
they have maintained all along that
secession is an implicit right that a
state that has surrendered some of its
sovereignty to the federal government
should have the right to reclaim it if
it was dissatisfied with the national
compact just like a contract if one
person violates the Accord then the
other presumably is released from the
contract while they came up with lots of
rationalizations and lots of legalistic
arguments to justify slavery the facts
still remained there was no explicit
permission for it to be done for it to
happen in the Constitution so the
confederates are framing their new
constitution the big debate is well we
should make it explicit we should make
this sacred right part of our Organic
Law but then some say wait a minute if
we make it explicit in our Constitution
that might make people think we weren't
sure it really was implicit in the old
one and then beyond that others say my
god if we make slavery and explicit
right and one of us does to us what
we've just done to the north we've had
it
so in the end their Constitution is
completely silent on secession but there
are a few especially the the real
hardcore fire-eating ideologue people
like Robert barn will read of South
Carolina who are immediately unhappy
with everything that's happening in the
Confederacy because it isn't doing what
they want it to do and some of them will
in fact as time goes on say we made a
mistake joining the Confederacy we ought
to secede from it and just go it alone
it's never seriously discussed there are
stories in 1864 when Georgia's invaded
Sherman's armies are marching toward
Atlanta that governor Joe Brown who is
the Great Satan of the Confed
so far as Jefferson Davis is concerned
he's a he's a born controversy list if
Jefferson Davis said the sun is shining
Brown would say no it isn't without
looking out the window
he just had to gain say whatever Davis
said there are stories that Brown was
willing to talk about making a separate
piece with Sherman and perhaps even
trying to get the legislature to pull
Georgia out of the Confederacy back to
the Union but a lot of that is is murky
and apocryphal certainly there were no
attempts for for a secession from the
Confederacy at the end yes sir Civil War
history
that's a great question if somet so much
of the archives of the records of the
Confederacy had not been destroyed with
the fall of Richmond with the story
would what historians say about the war
be different and I'm sure some elements
of it are
remember history is not what happened
history is what people write about what
happened which is which is why history
has no business being the social
sciences it is a literary art or ought
to be most of Richmond most of the
government offices in Richmond were not
prepared for the evacuation Davis had
not prepared the executive offices
Treasury State some of the other offices
were not prepared the only one that was
prepared was the War Department because
a new Secretary of War had come in in
February 1865 man named John C
Breckinridge who came in knowing the
game was up and among the first things
he did was begin preparing for the
evacuation of Richmond which he knew was
going to happen and he had the War
Department archives boxed and on a train
ready to get out of Richmond 137 years
ago Tuesday I guess and had them
protected under guard all the way as the
Confederate government fled south until
finally under his order the archives are
turned over to the Federals to ensure
that some of the Confederate story could
be told but other departments most sadly
I think the State Department were not
prepared and in the confusion on April
2nd when Richmond is being abandoned
just boxes of papers are brought out
into the streets and bonfires are lit
and much of the story of the Confederate
State Department and diplomatic efforts
simply went up in flames
unfortunately also that some of those
papers got caught up in a breeze and are
swept all over Richmond contributing to
the fires that were already going so you
know there's there's a kind of a sort of
Edgar Allan Poe s sort of poetry about
the fact that the story of the
Confederacy is being consumed in flames
in itself helping to consume the
Confederate capital who knows how
different the story would be the
military story I think would not change
but much of the internal story of the
Confederate government might
anyone else yes sir with the spotlight
being slave in Battersea
I love you ask me if I'm right or wrong
I'm not sure
is it true
during Warren after war
the question is were there slave states
within the Union during the war and
there certainly were Missouri Kentucky
Maryland and Delaware Delaware a slave
state there's only about four slaves
there by 1861 but it's still officially
a slave state and it's not-it's no
surprise that these are the states right
on the border between the free states
and the Confederate states these are the
states that are the most conflicted they
have some family ties not just in
slavery but a familial ties with people
in the deep south but their business
ties are mostly with the people of the
north they lose no matter what they do
or at least that's the fear they have
Kentucky will actually in the summer of
1861 declare itself neutral I mean
imagine if we went to war with Canada
and Montana says we're neutral but
Kentucky simply couldn't decide they
lost no matter what they did
Maryland remains iffy as to which way
it's going to go and the Lincoln
government will exercise some somewhat
extra legal coercion just to make sure
Maryland doesn't try to secede because
if it did Washington DC is isolated
between two slave states but
overwhelmingly even in Maryland but
especially in Kentucky and Missouri the
sentiment is pro-union now these states
will all send regiments into both
northern and southern armies but they're
essentially more loyal to the Union
because their interests are primarily up
there yes sir
genomics cost review
I'm sorry economics to what extent did
economics impel the union to fight the
war they aren't really talking much
about economics in 1860 and 61 after now
the tariff issue of course had and you
want to put an audience to sleep talk
about the tariff for a while but the
tariff it ceased to be there's no
question in the 1820s and 30s there was
a discriminatory tariff in place that
put onerous burdens on southern
consumers who tried to buy foreign goods
and this of course leads to the crisis
of 1832 and 33 and the first time that
South Carolina at least comes close to
talking about secession they don't but
at least that brings up the subject by
1860 the tariff had died is an issue you
really don't hear about it after about
1850 because successive changes in the
tariff laws have more or less equalized
and finally the Walker tariff act of I
think 1857 essentially it's just not
enough of an issue for people to get
excited about the proof in the pudding
is that in March 1861 after they frame
their constitution when the Confederates
are enacting all their statute laws they
impose the Walker tariff act on
themselves
what about the economic impact of export
tariffs on the funding funding of the
federal government I'm a little hazy on
that don't you here love it when a
historian says I don't know
is greatly derived from agriculture
mostly action
and all of the fun
well actually it's also derived from the
sale of the public lands there are two
sources of it the 11 stations to see the
red masters
yeah okay I'm gonna keep going yeah
there is an argument that's made that
it's made after the war chiefly by a guy
named Alfred Taylor Bledsoe who
interestingly enough even the other
authors of the Lost Cause myth ignore
but he makes this argument that Lincoln
really wasn't fighting the war to hold
the kids of the Union that he was doing
it to keep a grip on these other tariffs
well there's a basic problem with it now
I think anybody can probably figure out
what you would do the tariff is the
prime of exports and imports eyes and
duties are the primary source of income
for the federal government also sale of
the public lands but in those days
correct me if I'm wrong George you may
know work or will on a daily basis the
tariff produced maybe twenty or thirty
thousand dollars a day yep six or seven
eight million dollars a year the full
federal budget was under ten million
dollars a year that's less than a
congressman spends on a fact-finding
trip to Bermuda with his secretary today
the Civil War costs the north a million
dollars a day I think somebody would
stand up and say wait a minute we're
spending a million dollars a day to hold
on to twenty thousand dollars a day and
figure that ain't a good deal
interestingly enough tariff income in
the north into and out of northern ports
increases once the war starts even
though they no longer have all those
southern ports as points of entry and
export so obviously no nation wants to
lose a substantial portion of his income
but I think Lincoln would have had an
enormous time persuading farmers in
Illinois and Ohio let alone Democratic
politicians in New Hampshire or
Pennsylvania to prosecute that bloody
that cost a four-year war to hold on to
tariff revenue that thanks to northern
growth in industry is already growing
from their own exports and if I talk
about tariffs anymore I'll put me to
sleep that's yes ma'am
and this one
mm-hmm
there's
but there's no question that some some
Cherokee and other Indians were property
owners and did own slaves particularly
was a John Ross I think who's one of the
early leaders of the Cherokee Nation I
don't know a stand what he was or not
but but certainly some of them did you
know there are some free blacks in the
Confederacy who owned slaves slavery is
a sign of status a slave is also someone
to to help you with the produce of your
farm or to print or to run your business
anybody could own a slave you didn't
have to be a citizen whether or not
that's the reason the Cherokee largely
sided with the south is hard to saying I
confess I don't know a lot about that
the poor Indians especially out in my
part of the country Kansas and Missouri
and they're about we're kind of used by
both sides taking advantage of old inter
tribal rivalries so if one tribe of
Indians sided with the Confederacy their
ancient enemies would side with the
Union and neither side used them very
well or took very good care of them yes
sir
god I hate reviewers why do I put so
many big words and books as such has
nobody on so nobody'll know what I'm
saying
I'll try to use shorter words I think on
that note we'll close how do you top
that thank you all very much for being
here tonight
I guess you folks won't get to sign
books I'll just sit down over here and
start William C Davis is director of
programs at the Virginia center for
civil war studies at Virginia Tech in
Blacksburg look away a history of the
Confederate States of America is
published by the Free Press and you can
visit the Free Press com to get more
information